before we say goodbye let's play a quick
round of truth or dare
all right
all right and here we have chris beat
you hi chris hi how are you
thank you for being here of course of
course all right so you have a choice
you can either have us do a truth or you
can dare us to do something what's it
going to be um i'm going to do a drew
drew okay hit it you can't handle it so
the cooking something the cooking
segments are my favorite and i love all
your recipes but i was wondering do you
have like a cooking fail
a cooking fail okay on the show my worst
like
trigger moment of i was with giada de
laurentiis and i learned that if you are
adding parmesan or cheese to your pasta
making like a cachoe pepe
for example
take it off the heat or it will become
snotty cobwebs
and not this beautiful
like thing that it's supposed to be so
when you are putting cheese in your
pasta take it off the heat that's that's
something i learned the hard way
and i really wanted to impress her
and i just felt like a total tool bar
but i learned you learned but i think
you should make mistakes in the kitchen
that's that's why it's there like
there's there's recipes but there are no
rules and you learn from the mistakes so
get in there get your hands dirty and
screw up every once in a while all right
i need your inner dialogue yeah
all right thank you chris so very much
thank you everyone for spending your
time with us we make this show for you
so please take it with you
[Applause]
[Music]
you